plutôt bien j'étais plutôt confiant
j'avais plutôt l'impression qu'il
pouvait se passer quelque chose que mon
à travers ce que l ai pu me dire aimé
jacquet sur ce qu'ils ressentent et du
groupe
je pensais que l'équipe de france
pouvait l'emporter ouais il ya le début
mai 3 0 c'est un exceptionnel comme ça
dans la première mi temps a été
exceptionnel d'abord la première mi
temps c'était les français qui étaient
les brésiliens puisque l'équipe de
france a mieux joué mieux maîtriser le
ballon fait circuler le ballon avec
beaucoup plus de fluidité beaucoup plus
de rapidité que ses adversaires enfin
c'était vraiment et neutraliser des
stars comme ronaldo ou autre mais à
votre avis les raisons de la victoire ça
s'est pas fait à soi ça se travaille
depuis longtemps comment est-ce qu'on
est arrivé qu'est-ce qu'on a créé comme
esprit dans cette équipe de france pour
qu'elle arrive à cette victoire hier
soir les premiers vainqueurs sont les
joueurs avec leurs entraîneurs je pense
que mes jacques est depuis 1996 pour
sortir de l'euro il a pendant deux ans
fixé comme objectif être champion du
monde et il a préparé tout ce parcours
même s'il a été parfois chaotique encore
qu'élu très très peu de déchets même
s'il a été parfois en main et vient
justement décrié lui avait une logique
et il a été jusqu'au bout de sa logique
avec ses joueurs pour terminer comme il
a terminé hier soir
cela étant c'est vrai que vous avez
raison c'est quelque chose qui se
prépare en amont depuis longtemps nous
avons besoin de pallier à une culture
sportive qui n'est pas aussi forte
qu'elle ne l'est dans d'autres pays ont
par conséquent chaque fédération
s'efforce de développer d'avoir des
actions c'est ce que nous avons fait
depuis 20 ans avec
monsieur boullane lorsqu'il était
directeur technique scheer est que
depuis dix ans on a mené un certain
nombre d'actions à l'intérieur de la
direction technique avec tous les
entraîneurs qu'ils soient amateurs ou
professionnels ça donne cette qualité de
joueur on en est content de cette
victoire c'est une chance pour le
football j'imagine que ça va changer des
choses justement oui c'est à mon avis
j'espère d'abord que ça va faire
reconnaître le football parce que pour
éviter d'être déjà quand même écouté
j'ai envie de dire que depuis la
libération il n'y a pas eu autant de
scènes de liesse et j'irai de joie dans
le nain dans les rues de toutes les
villes de france et de paris
moi j'ai vu aussi beaucoup de
personnages politiques qu assister au
match à plusieurs matchs peut-être
sentir à 8 ça je peux vous dire que la
manière là il était heureux pour les
avoir vus dans le vestiaire était
extrêmement heureux s'est passé dans le
vestiaire entre la rentrée le président
a des joueurs ce qu'ils avaient très
bien c'est que ce soit le président le
premier ministre
il n'y avait pas l'un qui serrait la
main d'un côté l'hôte de l'autre est une
espèce de dison de communion ils étaient
ensemble pour féliciter les joueurs
bref là c'était de deux grands
supporters heureux et est surtout
satisfait du travail qu'ils ont accompli
des joueurs un peu en dehors du
protocole là j'imagine mais c'était
surtout juillet une espèce de bonheur de
plénitude qui était partagé avec eux et
les joueurs est ce que vous pensez
qu'ils ont réalisés comme il était dans
les vestiaires je pense qu'ils vont
surtout réalisé aujourd'hui demain parce
qu'ils ont réalisé un fantastique
exploit enfin le l'impact et je dirais
les répercussions de ce type sont
phénoménales
j'imagine que c'est plutôt demain et
dans les jours qui vont suivre du conte
se rendre compte que grâce à eux il ya
une ligne dans le palmarès des coupes du
monde c'est français en 1998 mais vous
savez ce qu'ils ont fait cette note
clairefontaine
or il était en famille parce que
leurs femmes
il avait rejoint et donc ils ont
simplement décidé de passer la soirée
ensemble à clairefontaine où on a évoqué
à l'instinct aimé jacquet mais jacquet
vous le connaissez très bien parce que
vous étiez entraîneur de l'équipe de
france à cette fameuse coupe du monde 94
à laquelle la france n'a pas participé
et aimé jacquet a été votre adjoint
qu'est ce qui l'a amené de plus à votre
avis le forez lui demander à lui moi je
pense qu'une valise habitationnel il a
surtout et c c'est un technicien de dot
compétence qui est très qu'à une logique
qui suit sa logique
et puis qui est honnête
très franchement et qui en plus je dirai
au delà de tous à une vision et à partir
de cette vision il travaille pour
l'objectif alors vu que vous fassiez pas
trop bien compris moi je peux vous dire
que sincèrement pour l'avoir suivi pas à
pas c'est qu'il n'a jamais donné
l'impression de sortir un petit peu de
sa logique
par exemple pour gagner un titre comme
ça il faut être en il faut avoir une
très bonne équipe avec un bon banc de
remplaçants et la présence de franck
leboeuf qui doit remplacer laurent blanc
dans un match comme cela le match comme
une finale avec autant de brio prouve
qu'il avait réussi que j'ai fait le bon
choix
il faut aussi une bonne préparation
athlétique
or les joueurs viennent de faire sept
matches et n'ont pas donné l'impression
d'être poussif à la demande au dernier
match puisqu'ils ont même marqué un but
à 10 contre 11 contre les miens et puis
on a eu l'impression d'une force
collective intérieur on a l'impression
que si en même temps d'une sérénité
d'une force collective et ça constitue
ce groupe exactement alors vous l'avez
dit à l'instant aimé jacquet n'a pas
toujours été très bien compris il a même
été franchement critiqué par certains
quotidiens
qu'est ce que vous pensez de sa réaction
hier soir il a dit je ne pardonnerai
jamais mais tous les techniciens accepte
qu'on critique
les choix les options les orientations
le style de jeu un problème dans ce
domaine là parce qu'on accepte passé
lorsque ça devient blessant sur la vie
privée sur le look sur le charisme et
ses terrains et je pense qu'il a dû être
très heurté et blessé
nous l'avons été également pour lui la
certain nombre de critiques qui m'ont
semblé injuste et je dirais même qu'elle
offrait un des centres et il a confirmé
qu'il allait partir vous trouvez que
c'est il pourrait peut-être acheter non
non parce que bon c'est pas une
girouette il a annoncé depuis longtemps
qu'il qu'il partait il a annoncé que en
principe à la fin de la coupe du monde
il prendre du recul et le connaissant je
crois qu'il va maintenir sa position
on connaît le nom de son successeur non
pas du tout mais je crois que pleurer
janvier le président de la fédération
est en principe eux cette semaine avec
le conseil fédéral devrait donner un an
savent aller vite
oui je disais à l'instant on chuchote
beaucoup jean tigana comme écouter mon
jeu de tas de choses - ce qui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut surtout voir la
vie en bleu et se réjouir de ce qui
s'est passé je pense que dans les jours
qui viennent du successeur
interviendront une dernière question
cette équipe est jeune on le retrouvera
à peu près pareil en 2002 en corée japon
écoutez ça c'est là mon avis là aussi
une grande fierté qu'on peut avoir c'est
que bien sûr il ya des joueurs
expérimentés de laurent blanc didier
deschamps qui sont les leaders de ce
groupe mais il y a aussi un effectif qui
est encore assez jeune il ya des joueurs
qui avaient été en moins de 20 ans mais
les i l'an dernier et il y as derrière
deux générations de joueurs qui ont été
champions d'europe en 96 97
tu les as force un petit peu notre
football c'est de se dire qu'il ya des
joueurs de qualité et de la réserve
charruyer jour merci je vous souhaite
une bonne nuit peut-être maintenant non
parce que oui parce que vous avez fait
m'avait fait venir une heure des coûts
tout je suis un brasseur publiées et une
audience footballistique énorme
sauve grâce à tv5 seront reçus dans le
monde entier nos jours mais je pense
surtout à tous ceux qui ont fait la fête
hier soir et j'en étais
[Musique]